Hi, I'm John Green, and this is not Crash Course.
Instead, I'm here to talk about why we're hitting the pause button
on our human geography series to go back and rework it.
In the last few months, we've been trying to grow Crash Course,
both on the curricular side of things
and in terms of the number of videos we make per week
without increases to our budget or staffing, and that was a mistake.
It led to a rushed production schedule, inadequately edited and vetted scripts
and the Human Geography videos had factual mistakes as well as too strident a tone.
We wrongly lumped Jared Diamond in with racist colonial geographers
and we did a bad job of explaining what environmental determinism was
before saying that it had been wholly debunked, which is not accurate.
Crash Course needs to have a point of view,
but it also needs to be intellectually rigorous and to acknowledge the diversity of opinion
and research within a field, and we didn't do that.
So we've taken the videos down, and we will be back with the geography series in the future
that better reflects the diversity of contemporary approaches to the study of geography.
Our biggest takeaway from this experience is that Crash Course needs to work
with a larger team of educators and experts and spend more time vetting scripts
so that's going to be the first change we make.
That will slow down our production schedule
but ultimately I think it will also improve our videos.
I also want to say, "Thank you," to the many people
who shared reasoned, thoughtful, and constructive criticisms of Crash Course videos.
You make the channel better for us and for all those who watch it.
Snarky or abusive comments that don't come from a place of generosity
are really hard to respond to with anything but defensiveness, but we've been very lucky
at Crash Course that there are so many kind and careful critiques, and we're very grateful for them.
Last thing – I want to be clear that the fault for this lies with Stan and me
not with anyone else who works for Crash Course
and certainly not with the presenter of the videos, Miriam.
This one is entirely on us – mostly me – so I am the person you should be mad at.
I want to thank all of our staff and hosts for doing everything they can
to make high quality educational videos quickly and on a tight budget
and thanks to all of you for watching.
Human Geography, again, will be back in a few months.
In the meantime, there's still lots of great Crash Course to watch.
Thanks, bye.